so basically what happened was I had a
dream those are four words that will
have your man nervous I had a dream the
night before right that Rob online
cheated on me Sophie leaves Rob after
she finds out he's cheating on her
through a dream and I never check his
phone but I was like let me just check
because I had a dream about it and I
went on this one app and like basically
he's been getting like disgusting videos
from other women H Rob's friend is
worried about Sophie cheating on him
online
tell me why I saw Sophie on Bumble she
was in there looking for a Tenderoni in
a dateid of things bro he needs to be
worried about his bestie I'm not perfect
man I'm not
like I'm not perfect but I'm I'm
definitely not trying to be with nobody
else but you I just want you I want you
in my life oh
okay hey 90day fans fam it's melissia
Rob and Sophie have made it into the
group chat this is my first time talking
about them and I have a lot to say so
let's get into it just a little
background to catch everyone up Rob is
33 years old from Los Angeles and Sophie
is 23 from London these two come from
totally different backgrounds Sophie
comes from an affluent family and Rob is
out here just trying to make it oh my go
recently Sophie arrived in the us to
start her 90 days with Rob stop very
confused what is going on after he broke
out in this cringy dance that he
actually practiced he proposed and
Sophie said I do yes yes yes yes thank
you yes these two have been living in
Rob studio apartment that has an
ouse okay it might not be an ous but
it's a bathroom that you have to go
outside and use until in the morning if
I want to pee and it's like raining I've
got to walk out into the rain now before
before we get into Rob cheating their
most recent issue came up when Sophie
revealed she's not interested in getting
pregnant which blindsided Rob Sophie
just rocked my entire belief in in her
and what we can have why they didn't
have this conversation before getting
engaged your guess is as good as
mine this is 90day after all obviously
for me it's like I told you obviously
when I was 15 I had the cyst at the top
of this week's episode Sophie opens up
to Rob about the life-saving surgery she
had as a teenager and why is led to her
not wanting kids obviously for me it's
like I told you obviously when I was 15
I had the cyst and that was on my ovary
so I had surgery to remove it I kind of
just accepted the fact that like I don't
want to be pregnant after that Health
scare cuz like I could have died if they
didn't remove that you know and it was
like or if I would have not had it taken
out then I wouldn't have been able to
have kids so it's kind of that scar with
was enough for me to be like okay like I
can't carry a child so I guess I'm not
going to be a mom Rob and Sophie then
agree on the idea of possibly having a
surrogate surrogacy sounds like the
route that I'm more partial
to I think the surus SE thing like I'd
be okay with it which I don't know if
they thought that through because the
surrogate is super expensive and Rob
seems to be pretty conservative with his
money and that's to say the least I'm
going bring you down to earth a little
bit you want to be with me I'm a down
toe
person so yeah fast forward to the end
of the episode we see Sophie alone and
the message pops up on screen saying
that she called The Producers saying she
moved out of Rob's place the previous
night and is now rinting a
spot at first Sophie seems hesitant to
tell the producers what went down
between her and Rob and as she starts to
open up you see why basically
um so basically what happened was I had
a dream the night before right that Rob
online cheated on me which for those of
you who don't know it's something he has
done before I had a dream the night
before right that Rob online cheated on
me so the next day I just checked his
phone I never check his phone but I was
like let me just check because I had a
dream about it I went on his Instagram
didn't find anything and then I went on
this one app and like basically he's
been getting like disgusting videos from
other
women don't it don't it don't come on
baby don't that intuition came through
and like asking for just like nudes and
like the videos are disgusting I wonder
does she mean disgusting in terms of the
video being inappropriate or disgusting
meaning what she saw was real kinky what
would make this even worse is if he's
been entertaining these women online
while she's been with him in La like the
videos are disgusting and he's like
entertaining it and I was just like I
found videos and then I was just like
you need to drop me off I don't want to
talk to you like I just left I just had
to leave I was packing my stuff he was
trying to stop me like I just took what
I could and I and I left I threw the
ring I didn't have the ring anymore I
through the ring so yeah right
now did any of you start thinking about
your recent dreams I know I did similar
to Sophie I've had dreams that reveal
things I need to be aware of but I've
also had dreams that were all over the
place and just a manifestation of my
fears and worries so I say all that to
say don't have Sophie have you out here
accusing your partner of cheating just
because you had a dream I do believe
that dreams can hold messages but
they're not always black and white in
Sophie's case this time around it was
you H me again BR I guess during their
fight Sophie thought to pull out her
phone and record it for the show I would
love to know what her thought proc
process was in that moment but
nevertheless appreciate it because we
get to see Rob's initial reaction to
getting caught I've been trying to be
perfect but I'm not perfect man I'm not
like I'm not perfect but I'm I'm
definitely not trying to be with nobody
else but you I just want you I want you
in my
life Robert I'm assuming that's your
government name you say you only want
Sophie but the evidence messages of you
requesting sexual videos from other
women says the contrary you know one of
the things Rob said when we first met
him was this I wanted a fine woman I
don't know if he thought having a fine
girl would satisfy him but clearly it's
not he might have a problem based off
what we've seen on 90day there seems to
be a deep internal struggle in the guy
he can come off as unmotivated if we're
going through gos he's like ask your
family for money which does annoy me
quick to anger like I cheated on you
when I didn't why you angry at me
because I don't like that every time you
try to act like that was cheating that's
bull and just overall kind of
grumpy
what why are you angry at me why you
angry at me my God with all this
attitude over the damn elevator all that
to say I'm curious about what's driving
his behavior as a whole no wonder he
never ask me for sexual videos he's
getting them from like I don't know how
many
girls it's just a lot and I just he's
disgusting right now and I just don't
want to be like anywhere near him Sophie
goes on to say that some people might
not view this as cheating but to her it
is it is to me too he did this before
and I near broke up with him because it
was like just after a year I think after
we've been dated he did the same thing
and he was like ranking off back to us
right this is really explicit it is but
like he was he was doing inappropriate
stuff the girls inappropriate stuff and
it's like I said you can't hurt me like
this again if you do this I'm leaving so
he knew what he was doing on top of
being heartbroken Sophie feels lost
she's in this Airbnb that she's rented
because she doesn't have anywhere to go
or anyone to turn to in the states in
moments like this I really appreciate
the 90-day production crew because at
least she's not totally alone that's one
of the benefits of being on the show you
go live with someone you barely know in
a foreign country which could possibly
be one of the most dangerous ideas but
more than likely you'll be safe because
you're with the crew they're like
chaperon who don't interfere I don't
have anything don't even have a car so
it's like I don't have anywhere to go I
don't know what I'm supposed to do now
and obviously if I don't marry him I
have to go home so I've given up
everything for nothing girl that doesn't
mean stay sometimes you have to make a
U-turn she has to really ask herself
what's more important to her living in
LA and marrying a man who quite frankly
needs to get his stuff together or going
back home to London where she'll at
least have her peace and won't have to
walk outside to the bathroom every night
I don't want to throw away my whole life
that I've been trying to build to be in
LA with Rob it's like I've got I have to
give up that I have to give up that
dream and he just gets to live the same
life with no consequences he doesn't
have to leave he just gets to do what
he's doing you know sometimes you have
to pull out the handy dandy pros and
cons list as a viewer the only Pro I see
is Sophie living in sunny Southern
California but the cons one Rob wants
children and she seemingly doesn't
because of the fact that I don't want to
get pregnant it's I've never really
thought about kids kind of type thing
two she's living in an uncomfortable
environment three with a man who isn't
even treating her well he's cheating on
her I get making sacrifices when the
love is good but
it's not now if she has other
aspirations in Los Angeles outside of
Rob that she's not talking about that's
another conversation I just feel very
trapped and very alone and what he's
done to me it's like I'm hurt but at the
same time it's like I don't have
anywhere to go and I don't really know
what I'm supposed to do and I just feel
very it's a very lonely feeling and it's
very difficult to process and my mind's
just trying to like block the pain but
it is a bit
difficult
I'm just really trying not to think
about it it's
[Music]
hot that's the thing it's like it's not
even that Hur me it's that I don't what
am I supposed to do
now yeah I also find it interesting that
they're both hiding secrets from each
other well Rob's secret is out now but
Sophie is bisexual I've always known
that I was attracted to women cuz my
first crush when I was like five six
years old was a girl and the man she's
engaged to Mary has no clue that being
said I understand why Sophie is
heartbroken but at the same time I'm
learning that if you want your partner
to be honest and
loyal you have to practice those things
too and to take it even deeper you have
to practice being honest with you and
being loyal to yourself staying true to
you I believe our relationships tend to
mirror whatever is going on inside of us
forget Rob betraying her is Sophie
betraying herself by not fully owning
who she is and how she wants to express
herself like I probably should tell Rob
soon that I'm bisexual I've just been
pting it off for a bit I'm not saying
that she's a cause for Rob's Behavior no
not at all all I'm saying in my opinion
is that she has to give herself the same
treatment she wants to receive from
Rob what is this all right next week a
moment I've been waiting for since the
season's trailer dropped girl no one is
prepared for it Jasmine finds lip gloss
in Gino's
car what is
this I have no idea how they got there
or how long it's been I have learned to
read Gino I can tell his give you you're
a no I'm not yes you are yes you
that's not
cheat to
home
to oh I can't wait to see all right
90day fans spam make sure you stick with
ET because we are covering it all I will
see you next
time